you worked with james monaco
on the purge movie yeah uh and then you
you i guess you worked on with him again
on once upon a time in staten island
well i did two purge movies with him and
then once upon a time in staten island
which is
a complete 180 degree departure from
it's a real it's an amazing film it's
another film that got caught up with
covet
i can't wait for people to see this
movie what can you say about it because
obviously this is
uh i guess it must be autobiographical
for him
you know i i think part of it is and
then he
it's a family drama surrounded by this
idea
of staten island where he still lives
and and what
rocky the rocky movies represented in
the 80s
to all the people in staten island the
italian and irish americans right
and but it's what's inside of it is this
this broken little family
that goes on this journey and they each
each one of them
have have this this revelatory change by
the end of the film
and growth and naomi watts this is now
my third movie with her
she's so amazing to me she's the best
actress that i've ever worked with
uh and bobby cannavale is great uh
demonico
people will understand that how talented
this this guy really is
and we are talking him and i
about another purge movie what
yep for sure he reached out to me not
too long ago and and
sebastian the producer and they're like
what do you think and i'm like what do
you what do you think and they're like
we talk to universal and they want to
see
leo barnes and and you know in the fifth
purge if if we can come up with
something great i said
i'm in i'm i'm doing a heartbeat i was
gonna say i think there's another purge
movie
tentatively coming out this summer yeah
yeah i don't know if it'll hit the
theaters but yeah i mean at this point
who knows
um with are you a bit surprised at
because the purge movies i mean listen
people all these people talk about
making sequels to so many different
movies
you never know what's actually going to
get popular then you have a franchise
like the purge
which is you know they've made what five
movies six movies whatever the number is
what do you think it is about the purge
oh
yeah i mean he hit the button he you
know he connected to the zeitgeist
it's you know what would you do if you
could get away with anything
for 12 hours it's listen it's what would
you do with a million dollars it's one
of those scenarios it's everyone thinks
about it
well if i had a million dollars i would
well if i could kill this guy and get
away with it it would be
i would care and and so everybody can
relate to it
and it's it's uh you know
it's it's hyper realism the way he cuts
you know the way he shoots it it's
almost cartoonish
it's uh they're fun movies they're just
and people yeah i mean i i'm pr i'm
i think that purge anarchy movie is to
me
one of the coolest like b movies that
i've seen in a long time
and forbes magazine wrote a great
article about the importance of the
purge franchise
and how it relates to what we're going
through in the world
not in our country in the world so i i
you know i think they're i think they're
uh it's an important thing it's an
important franchise and so i
in a minute i would do another one